what i want to do in this video is talk
a little bit about money
and interest rates and do it in kind of
a micro economic framework so that we
understand the relationship between the
supply of money and demand for money and
the price of money which we'll see is
what interest rates actually are and
once we do that then we'll be able to be
more fluent in discussing money and
interest rates and supply and demand and
price of money in a macro economic
context so maybe the most confusing
thing when you view money in a
microeconomic context is what is the
price
what is the price of money
and you might already be guessing the
price of money is the interest rate and
to understand that a little bit better
the best way to think about it is you're
not necessarily buying money interest is
rent on money it is rent
on
it is rent on money if i said what is
the price of an apartment in my
neighborhood someone might say it is say
a one bedroom apartment and that
actually is pretty close to the prices
where i live here in northern california
if you want to even have the most basic
one bedroom apartment it's going to run
you about 1200 dollars
twelve hundred dollars per month
twelve hundred dollars per month which
is about what fourteen thousand four
hundred dollars
per year so we should say per apartment
per
apartment per per year this is
essentially the cost of your apartment
now if someone were to go if i went to
the bank and i said hey i want to borrow
i want to borrow 10 000 maybe i want to
buy a car or something
they would quote an interest rate they
would say okay you could borrow that at
an interest rate of i don't know
interest rates are pretty low right now
they'll say you could borrow that at an
interest rate at five percent and to see
that this is essentially the cost of
renting money we could essentially just
say that this is this is five
we could view this as five cents
five cents per
per dollar
per year
so once again when you're renting an
apartment it was fourteen thousand four
hundred dollars per apartment per year
now at an interest rate of five percent
that is five cents per dollar per year
it's the exact same thing this right
over here is this right over here is
the rent
on the rental price on the actual money
that i'm borrowing and once you have
that in your head and you feel
comfortable with that now we can
actually draw a supply and demand graph
and kind of the microeconomics context
now that we know how to think about the
price of money so let's draw
let's draw a little supply and demand
diagram right over here and we're going
to like we often do in our little
economic models we do we're going to
super oversimplify it we're going to not
think about people things like credit
risk and the percent and the chances the
probability that people do pay back or
won't pay back the money and things like
liquidity and all that we'll just assume
that everyone is going to pay back the
money and they all have the they're all
risk-free they're all going to do
exactly what they said
and so in this access right over here so
this is let's call this the market
let's call this the market for
market for
borrowing
money
for one year
one year and as we'll see and you might
already know they'll have different
prices for borrowing money for different
lengths of time i might charge you more
to borrow money for a year than i would
to charge then i would charge you for
borrowing money for a month because
maybe i you know i i won't be have
access to that money or there's a bigger
risk that something might happen in that
year so i'll charge you more for it so i
have to fix the year the market for
borrowing money for one year and most of
these supply and demand graphs the
vertical axis we have price but now as
we just indicated the price of money is
really just the interest rate so let me
i'll call this price
so this is our
same yellow so this is our price axis
price axis and it's measured as interest
rate
percentage interest
interest rate is how we're going to
measure it and let's say this right over
here let's say that that is 30 interest
this is 15 percent interest and then
this would be let's see this would be 10
5 this would be 20 25 pretty good and
then over here we would have the
quantity of money and i'll just pick
some values here let's see we could even
say that that is in you know i don't
know billions of dollars
we could size it right based on whether
talking about our town our city or
whatever the whole world or whatever it
is and it depends on what currency and
all of that board's assuming that we're
in some island with one currency you
know and and all the rest
and let's say that this is 1 billion 2
billion 3 billion 4 billion and 5
billion
and so you can imagine let's first think
about the demand curve we could think of
it as a marginal benefit curve
that that those first few dollars that
are out to be lent there are someone
who's going to get a huge marginal
benefit of it they want to take that
either they want to borrow it and use it
for some type of consumption that they
they something that they would they want
to buy that would make them very very
very happy or at least they think it'll
make them very happy or they want to use
it for some type of an investment where
they're like wow if i could just borrow
some money i have this no risk
investment that's just going to you know
make me a gazillionaire so those first
few dollars there's huge demand huge
marginal benefit for it and so the
willingness you could use as a
willingness to pay for those first few
dollars is very high so maybe it is way
up here people are willing to pay in
excess of 30 percent for those first few
dollars and then as there's more and
more dollars the incremental next
borrower gets a little bit less marginal
benefit from it and so you would have a
declining demand curve that looks
something like this and this is the
exact same thought process as you would
have if we were thinking about the
market for ice cream or if we're
thinking about the market for apartments
or anything else so this is our this is
our demand curve
and when we and when we think about the
supply curve same exact process thought
process as we would for
as we would for for supply of any
product so those first few dollars the
the people lending the money they're
like oh well they're probably people
they're willing to lend for very little
they have nothing else to do with that
money so they would you could another
way to think of it they have nothing
very they have very little to do with
that money their marginal cost of
lending that money is very low and so
the supply curve might start over here
people will start to be willing to lend
the money to very low interest rate this
is looks like about one percent and then
each incremental dollar the opportunity
cost for that lender is going to get
higher and higher and so the interest
the interest for that next incremental
dollar is going to get higher and higher
and so we've now drawn the supply and
demand graphs for
for the market for borrowing money for
one year so this is right here this is
this is the supply and this is in
billions of dollars let's say billions
of dollars per
per year so this is how much is go is
going to be lent in that year and it's
for borrowing money for a year but as we
see we can view money just like we could
view any other product there's going to
be an equilibrium price here in an
equilibrium quantity
so the way i drew it right over here the
equilibrium price and remember the price
of money is really just the interest
rate the equilibrium price right over
here is 10
which you could view as 10 cents per
dollar per year and the equilibrium
quantity of money that gets lent and
borrowed is looks like i don't know it
looks about 2.7 or 2.8 billion dollars
gets lent and borrowed in that year in
each year and when we look at it this
way then we can start thinking about
some macroeconomic phenomenon what
happens what happens if all of a sudden
if all of a sudden everybody everybody
in the world or in our little universe
right over here gets a little bit more
money thrown in their pocket so you know
the the the government prints about a
bunch of money drops it from helicopters
and everyone has more money in their
pockets well then all of a sudden
then all of a sudden at any given
interest rate the supply will go up at
any given interest rate the supply will
go up so the supply curve will shift in
this direction so we might have a new
supply curve that looks something like
this
so we might have a new supply curve that
looks something like this
and then also we could say well and also
maybe the demand will go down so any at
any given interest rate any given price
there will be less demand because those
people who need to borrow money now they
have to borrow less money and so this
will shift this will shift to the left
and so the new demand curve the new
demand curve might look like that now
what happened what would be our new
equilibrium price
and it depends how much i shift one or
the other but the way i drew it our
equilibrium quantity doesn't change much
but it could change depending on how
much the supply or the demand shifts but
what does definitely happen when that
money got printed and distributed to all
of these people is now all of a sudden
the equilibrium interest rate has gone
down the equilibrium interest rate now
based on the way i drew it looks like
it's closer to about i don't know about
six percent so the whole and you could
even think of another reality where all
of a sudden money disappears from the
market or reality where for whatever
reason because of good marketing or
psychological shift in people all of a
sudden people want to uh
people want to save less so that there
is less supply of money or maybe all of
a sudden there's all these great
investment opportunities so now there's
more demand for money and you could
think about how these curves would shift
and what would happen to the interest
rate just how you would think about it
for any good or service in a
microeconomic context